one other super interesting aspect of
your world view is your big supporter of
Biden
can you explain what you love Baba and
do you love Biden more than Sean Carroll
or less Sean Carol is just like in
another world of admiration I feel like
I'm culturally appropriating You by
saying gotcha now but it's so convenient
it's an easy word you're just like no
we're on the same wavelength okay we're
synchronizing that's good I mean it is
really interesting because even the
people that support Biden usually don't
say they love
sort of they don't support it strongly
you know ideologically philosophically
the reason why I like Biden is because
he's really committed to this bringing
the left and right together which is
something we so desperately need in the
country and his you know statements over
and over again of like I'm not a the
Democrat president or the Republican
president I'm the president of the
United States his desire to bring
Republicans together to work on things
like the infrastructure bill
um that's so incredibly needed and I
have a huge amount of respect and
admiration for him for trying to push
through on that message do you think
then it's unfortunate that he made that
comment about Maga Mega Republicans yeah
I mean I forget what the comment was but
it's Mega Republicans are not good
people kind of there I watched the full
video and he's right there is this toxic
aspect and it's hard to call out because
they're always going to spend like oh he
hits our Republicans he's not if you
watch the quote he's very specifically
calling out like this this group of
people that think that the election was
fraudulent is it clear it is what he
meant by we can bring it up all right
this is oh no oh did I remember watching
our stream it was like if you said it
yeah that's bad you're probably like
YouTube maggot Republicans Biden but
like it feels like it's pretty clear
he's talking about the people that are
like election denying
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
I want to be very clear listen to this
part clear up front
foreign
not every public and not even the
majority Republicans are Maggie
Republicans
not every Republican Embraces their
extreme ideology
I know
because I've been able to work with
these mainstream Republicans
but there's no question
that the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
I disagree with that man he didn't
Clearly say
extremist ideology he didn't say the
people that dialed the validity of the
election I mean that's Donald Trump no
but there's that's all the candidates
that Donald Trump is supporting how many
what is it like 40 50 how many
candidates right now that are Mega
candidates are electioned no but there's
uh you know 80 million or whatever
people voted for Donald Trump you could
say that's the matter Republicans so it
to me it sounded like he was referring
to
not even the majority I mean that that's
one nice helpful clarifying
statement but basically there's the
mainstream Republicans and then there's
those that voted for Donald Trump that's
the way I heard it okay and it's like so
maybe you should have done a better job
at clarifying but yeah I feel like
there's like a clear there is a huge
problem with this group of Americans I
think like the election is stolen I feel
like that's what he's trying to no
matter
if that's what he meant
even flirting with that line is not a
person who's bringing people together I
feel like the extending a hand to the
like most I've worked with republicans
in Congress not all but not even a
majority of Republicans are like this
no but why say not the majority of
Republicans that like to say like we are
like we're one country we believe the
same thing so like focus on the uniting
part versus something he does before and
after that was 50 seconds okay but that
you never know the point is you never
say something like that listen like that
you you've spoken about the Bosnia
speech which is your favorite of his
yeah I went back to and listened to it
before I move to that just on this it's
really hard for him to call out that
group of like election deniers I think
without it always feeling well why call
them out because it's arguably one of
the most destructive forces that exists
in this country today did it destroy
anything they were trying to did it
though
it didn't did it so does that mean we
don't call it out we wait till next time
because calling it out is giving fuel to
the division
like the people that doubted the
validity of the election that's anger
that's frustration with the other side
you heal that as opposed to saying all
those people that believed that at any
time are idiots they're Un-American I
mean they don't think the election was
real I don't know if Biden has The Heirs
of these people at all I don't know what
he can do for there's people that
believe the same thing on the in 2016
with the Russian hacking right there's
this down hold on yes
that is a super not fair comparison
there were definitely the mainstream
Democrat opinion was that Russian
um intrusion in terms of like social
media and stuff happen but there was
never a claim that like the election was
stolen no main or at least I don't know
of any mainstream Democrat that
supported that Donald Trump is not just
saying there was interference about a
lot Donald Trump is literally saying the
election was literally stolen that vote
boxes where ballot boxes were hidden
that vote tallies were manipulated that
I think the claim is there's a huge Gulf
of difference in the two so you can
attack Donald Trump for that yeah I
believe it's not the words of a uniter
to attack
people that believe that
You could argue maybe it's okay
but especially not being super clear
about that about who you're referring to
when you say mega Republicans okay
because Maga
is a hat
and a slogan
that refers to
whatever the number is 70 million people
whoever that voted for Donald Trump
like if all the Republicans are consider
this Mega Republicans what percentage of
them do you think believe the election
was stolen
feel like that number is I don't have
the Palm but I feel like your number is
like probably more than 70 percent
what's what's America Republican maybe
I'm not like Trump like a trump
supporting Republic a mega Republican
they're there for Trump
what's the difference between somebody
that voted for Trump and uh Mega
Republican and America Republican so my
mom is a mega Republican if Trump ran
independently and DeSantis ran under the
Republican ticket my mom would vote for
Trump She'll follow him to the end of
the Earth that's like a mega Republican
I think it's easy to mistake that
distinction
in these kinds of political speeches
because to me anybody who voted for
Trump can easily in the cut in the
context of the speech be interpreted as
a matter of Republican gotcha
I understand what you're saying maybe he
could have been more clear but like I
think in listening to that like
I think it's pretty obvious who he's
talking about but I guess if you have an
emotional response to it I can
understand the emotional response but
there's a lot of people I don't have an
emotional response I just don't like I
think uh I'm with what is it Michelle
Obama they go low we go high
meaning like to me a uniter doesn't
participate in derision sure unite or
might not but a leader has to be able to
accurately assess the situation before
him and make people aware of what's
going on you mean all the impeachment
trials all the censoring from social
media all of that didn't do the job
that's not his job I don't know that
mechanism his job is to inspire a nation
to unite a nation how can he do that
when half the people don't believe that
he was even legitimately elected like I
think he's done a good job at working on
legislation and doing stuff that
hopefully benefits all Americans but I
think it's important to recognize that
like there is a contingent of Americans
that don't even believe like this is
very plenty of people that recognize
that and are fighting that and are
constantly screaming that from the
rooftops his job is to be the inspiring
figure that makes the majority of
Americans be proud for him to be a
president of of the nation they love and
that's what the United aspect is is you
remind people that we are one and we
love this country love the ideas that it
represents who does that in other parts
of that speech it's like a 20 minute
speech isn't it but that's a [ __ ] up you
just don't participate in that division
anyway I I understand I understand I
just wanted to push back on the saying
one of the strength is that he's uh
he's uniting but yes that
that is an ideal that is a goal is a
great one and he is one that
um espoused that goal uh for a long time
do you think um
what else does it so from policy
perspective and so on I thought the way
he's handled Ukraine and everything thus
far has been almost perfect I think he
did a really good job
um at the political maneuvering and
bringing other countries into the fold
at establishing clearly like what our
mission was in relation to Ukraine I
thought he did a good job there I admire
him for pulling out of Afghanistan even
it was a little bit rough around the
edges like we got out and we're gone no
American lives are lost
um
the domestic policies passed more major
legislation than I think anybody thought
possible
um the green energy stuff for the last
bill the infrastructure Bill a lot of
the coronavirus relief I thought was
really good especially expansion of the
child tax credit
um so from a policy perspective for an
end domestic I think he's been
successful rhetorically I think he's
generally been above board in terms of
like not attacking people being too
divisive he's trying to bring people
together and work on them what do you
think about the sort of popular in the
media criticism of his mental decline do
you think he's experiencing it no he's
not a guy
what do you think I mean I do
yeah maybe a little bit but he's still
doing a good job so you know not from a
speech perspective you mean from a
policy perspective yeah I'm analyzing it
as a job yeah from speech perspective
maybe not the greatest but um yeah I
mean he's definitely what is he like 80
81 how old is he I lose track after so
many years yeah
but you did say that he's probably going
to run in 2024 and he's probably going
to win did I say that that he's probably
gonna win no way did I say that
somewhere he's probably gonna run okay
uh who knows who will win but I think um
I feel like the incumbent Advantage is
so strong you're really gonna throw that
away like thanks to like one or two
times in history in the US right where
like the non-income the parties put
somebody else up yeah I mean the the
concern is like the just the age and the
the the the mental decline just the
the wear and tear of the campaign all
that kind of stuff all the speech you
have to make the debates and all that
kind of stuff yeah so you see what
happens
what the least excited uh I mean two
years when I was a long time and his
current mental state yeah he could run
and do it he could do a passable job in
two years man I don't know I've seen
videos of Bill Clinton recently he's
looking pretty rough
um you know if Biden is looking a lot
more rough worse for wearing two years
then maybe they actually do have to dig
out another person uh for run I own us